Hold on.
Wait.
OK.
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello.
I'm back.
Hi!
Oh, thank you for the bargain deal!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
Welcome back to Lifeline.
I was going to say something and I don't remember what.
Ash, look at the membership!
It means it was my birthday today!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Rin.
Happy birthday!
Rio, welcome to membership!
Okidoki!
I'll be honest.
I don't quite remember how to play this game.
I think I remember, but...
Tomorrow is my birthday.
MGS2 was my first ever in the series.
I beat it a dozen times trying to understand it before finding MGS1.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, MercyKilled.
Happy birthday!
Sorry that I had to push this day.
If you're watching the VOD, then...
That already happened.
It might not matter so much to you.
But because of that, today might not be such a long stream.
Since I'm playing later from when I was initially going to play.
Hello, VODWaters.
VODWaters?
VODWatchers!
Everybody say hello to the VODWatchers!
Hold on, let me try and remember...
OK, I clearly don't remember how to play this.
I forget that square is confirmed in this game.
Oh my gosh, OK.
OK, hold on.
Is he actually watching me?
Yes, please, Rio!
Hold on!
Hold on, Rio.
OK.
It's my birthday in 10 months.
We'll see you in 10 months!
Oh yeah, let her sit down, you know.
Annunciate, I'm annunciating!
I'm annunciating.
OK, this is our items.
R1 is items.
I'm trying to figure out what the...
If there's like a...
What's the word?
A...
Oh gosh.
You know.
A controller...
Guide.
Tells me this button does this.
And there goes X-Ray the Thundercrafter!
Rio is crashing out.
I'm crashing out!
OK.
And then I also, I think it's...
Huh?
Hello!
Hello.
Huh?
Look at me.
The bed, OK?
No!
Huh?
Rio, we just started!
What?
There's not even a bed in here!
We're in the infirmary!
OK, let me do a quick recap.
Sorry, my brain's a little scattered today.
I had quite a bit going on.
Quiet.
Be quiet.
Stop!
Oh my god!
She wants me so bad.
What?
So, we are...
We are a dude guide.
Is he actually watching me?
She's talking about us, right?
And basically, a recap of the game from last time is...
We were on this fancy space station.
And suddenly...
Aliens attacked!
And...
We got separated from our girlfriend, Naomi.
And we woke up.
We were in the security room.
And we're watching...
Aren't there any instructions?
We're watching this lovely lady, Rio.
And we're giving her...
We're giving her instructions.
Directions on what to do and things of the such.
I heard there might be another MGS collab again in Fortnite.
Oh yeah, I saw that too!
I did see that.
Please, Ocelot, the boss, Gray Fox.
I think they'll probably put in Naked Snake, but...
I wonder if people will complain.
Because Naked Snake and Solid Snake...
Is he actually watching me?
Kinda look similar, you know?
So...
Yeah, I'm watching you!
I'm watching you.
Yes.
What?
Stop.
Yes.
What do you mean, yes?
To where?
I think we're just about to...
Do a boss fight, so I'm a little nervous.
Not even 10 minutes in and it's an amazing start.
Take a drink when she says the bed?
Oh no, no!
You mean a drink of water.
Do a sexy pose.
The crack!
Holy moly!
Rio!
Do a sexy pose.
Peach!
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches...
Oh my god!
I don't think I can...
I can't zoom when she does that.
See, watch.
Zoom.
Oh wait, hold on.
There's like a special mode I have to go into.
What's it called?
Oh, in consultation, that's right.
Consultation.
Where am I?
How's the...
How's the audio by the way?
Testing your own patience today?
Thanks for all the peaches.
Is the drink of water game the VOD water?
What?
Good audio?
Okay, thank you.
What else was there?
What should we do?
Oh yeah!
Yeah.
That's right.
I said we were about to go do a boss.
We're about to fight this spider monster.
And we're trying to blow it up?
Fire.
Okay, well...
I'll just say, leave.
Oh, stop.
Okay, that's it for consultation.
Then we're going to go...
RID OF SPIDERS!
Leave.
Leave room.
Yes, see?
There she goes.
Alright.
I don't know why she doesn't understand leave, but she understands leave room.
Alright, let's go defeat the spider monster.
I'm fully prepared to defeat that spider.
It's on the other side of Shutter 4.
How to become a member on my mobile?
Oh, I think there's like...
Some...
If it's like...
Apple phone?
Isn't it like weird to become a member?
I don't remember exactly.
But thanks for trying, Jeremy.
Okay, so it is at Shutter 4.
No, 3.
3?
Shutter 3.
Go to Shutter 3.
Okay.
Run.
Yes.
I love telling her to run.
Okay.
Thanks for the hint.
You guys are cute.
Oh no, I'm scared.
What am I...
The shutter is open.
What should I do?
Is it Shutter 4?
Oh, maybe it's Shutter 4.
Go to Shutter 4.
Shutter 4.
Okay.
Oopsie.
Run.
Yes.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Anyways, how are you guys doing today?
How are you guys doing?
Okay, I'm going to do my best.
I'm scared.
Great.
Good.
Do or die.
Oh my God.
Look at her.
Look at me.
Yes, I'm ready.
She's so... Look at her.
Look at me.
Oh my God.
Wait, I think we should open the door first.
Or maybe actually...
Yes.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Oh God.
Use your eyes, Rio.
If I wave this around, the spider won't be too eager to get close.
There's only one Molotov cocktail.
If we blow it, I'm as good as dead.
Okay.
Okay, it's time to waste that spider.
Open the shutter.
Oh my God.
Oh Rio.
No pressure, right?
Oh my God.
Here it comes.
Here it is.
Okay.
The pressure.
What?
I'm watching.
Does that count?
Throw!
I missed.
Oh my gosh.
But it's mouth was open.
Is it this difficult?
Oh my gosh.
Up.
Get up.
Leave room.
Okay.
I'll leave.
The mouth was open, right?
Voice QTE.
How long do I have to wait for it to be open for?
How...
Run...oh.
Yes.
Rio?
Run to shutter 4.
No!
Stop.
Go to shutter 4.
Run.
You said it when it went back up, I think.
Oh my goodness.
So I have to be like super duper fast.
Is this really that hard of a boss fight?
Oh geez.
Okay.
Time the time cycle.
I like the music though.
No!
Oh no wait!
I'm ready.
She's like I get it though.
I get it.
I wish I could skip this cutscene.
No you can't skip.
Okay.
I like the way she looks at me here though.
Yeah you are girl!
Okay.
You could use your own eyes.
The spider won't be too eager to get close.
There's only one molotov cocktail.
If we blow it, I'm as good as dead.
Okay, it's time to waste that spider.
Open the shutter.
Okay!
I kind of am obsessed with the death sequence though.
It's so funny.
Oh no!
I missed!
Can he hurt her?
Like can the monster hurt her?
Or is it just I keep timing him?
Oh no!
I missed!
It's afraid of the fire.
Just keep shooting it maybe.
Oh it had it's mouth open.
Okay.
Okay!
Okay so once it's on the ground, I...
What?
Oh!
First
try baby!
Let's go hurry up.
She's got good aim.
Yes!
Thank you.
Kudos to you!
Yeah, you tell him!
Oh!
Yeah, you tell him.
What?
Who are you?
This guy sounds like an alien trying to sound like a human.
What?
What do you mean you are partly to blame?
UFO!
I had opposed the opening of this hotel, but JSL refused to heed my warnings.
In preparation for possible disaster, I kept a rescue team on standby.
They are on their way here now.
You should make your way to the receiving port.
I will catch up after I find Alan.
I found your assistant unconscious in his room.
Dude was standing there the other time.
What is this?
Is Alan safe?
I wouldn't know.
There's even a good chance he's dead.
You need to hurry.
I thought you needed to get through here.
Don't go the opposite way.
Rio!
Oh my God!
A major wobble was detected in the safe station's rotation.
The station was placed on emergency status.
Although the wobble will not interfere with its orbit.
The gap section, however, had to be completely sealed off.
This completely blocks the way again.
But good thing this section wasn't sealed off.
One major wobble!
Not much else we can do besides obtaining a shutter key.
I'm Major Wobble.
What a cute name.
Oh, we're going to the restroom.
Restroom.
She's got such an attitude.
Jessie!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Major Wobble.
Look out for Major Wobbles.
Yes, I want that to be my general.
Major... not general.
You know, in the army, I would love to be called Major Wobbles.
Go to restroom.
Run.
Oh gosh, I know I'm going to be fighting stuff in there.
I know I'm going to be attacked, ambushed.
Oh gosh.
I need to remember how to fight.
Shoot number two.
Oh my gosh, wait, this is the perfect place to shoot!
You seem to be out in the back.
Listen, do you know the story?
What?
That if you die in space, your soul wanders through space forever?
Who said that?
The restroom in the guest section?
Well, there are these spooky rumors.
At night, even though there's supposed to be no one around, you can hear the sound of a music box.
When they were building the outer wall of the station, there was an accident involving some workers, and three were lost.
Two were miraculously rescued, but the last worker was never recovered.
That worker, he's said to have worn a pendant with a family photo and a music box.
Listen, operator.
How good are you with stories like this?
I'm a ghost.
What I mean is, do you get scared by ghost stories?
Yes.
Oh.
I don't believe in stories like that either.
I guess we're alike that way.
General Jiggle.
What was that sound?
Ryo, I'm scared.
Ryo, hold me.
Ryo, when did this turn into a horror game?
I must have imagined it.
I didn't imagine it.
Ryo, who was falling?
Oh my gosh.
What do you mean?
Go.
Go further.
Yes.
I'm probably leading her to her death, but...
Oh my gosh.
I'm scared.
General Jiggle.
Is it a real ghost?
Check door number one.
Yes where?
Where are you going?
I'm scared.
Guess what?
What?
Where is she going?
Ryo?
Okay.
Turn around?
I said look behind you.
Go to bathroom.
It was so easy.
How do I get her to go in there?
Is that a save station?
Actually, that's a good question.
Go to save point.
Yeah, thank you.
Actually, you kind of saved me.
You actually kind of saved me.
Thank you.
Who said that?
Marads, thank you.
Restrooms.
Okay.
Got nice.
Yeah, we would have to do the boss fight again.
This game isn't...
Okay, now let's see.
What's the map?
The guy, unless he's a pervert, he would be in the men's stalls, right?
She said it was a guy that died.
But we heard the music box come from the ladies' stalls.
Go to ladies' stalls.
I'm scared.
You're scaring me.
How do I tell her to go in?
Oh, there we go.
How do I...
Where did the hints go?
Stall 1.
Knock, knock.
Rex!
It's my birthday!
Of course!
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Rex!
What's the last one though?
What's that last door?
Go to door.
Door.
Door, door.
Go to door.
Door.
Closet.
Okay, the closet.
Open the door.
It's locked.
It appears to be a number lock type.
Number lock type.
Can you open it operator?
On.
8.
Go to wash stands.
Why there is a wash stand?
Why not a sink?
Oh, shiny.
Check mirror.
The mirror.
Check left mirror.
She was the one who was telling the ghost.
She psyched herself out.
Check middle mirror.
Check right mirror.
Oh yeah.
Bloody Mary.
Search.
What exactly?
Trash.
Are you maybe talking about that?
Oh yeah, we could shoot the mirror, right?
Search trash can.
It's an ordinary trash can.
No, there is something in there.
I know it.
Oh my gosh.
Search behind trash can.
It's an ordinary trash can.
There is probably...
Shoot mirror.
Check inside trash can.
No, there is not, madam.
Auto fire?
That sounds huge actually.
Ok, awesome.
What was this?
It was a stall, right?
Ladies stalls.
I don't think we checked each door, right?
So, what is it?
Check stall left.
Check stall middle.
Check middle stall.
What happens if you just shout boo?
Boo!
Bad posture.
No, she's all like... She's scared.
Check right stall.
Probably.
Check middle stall.
Ok, never mind.
Check stall 2.
I give up.
Ok, to the men's.
Go to men's stalls.
Which stall was that?
The men's stalls.
Is this how it feels like talking?
Run.
No, I'm scared.
She won't run.
Go to men's stalls.
The men's stalls.
She won't run because she's too scared.
No.
Is that a closet?
Men's stalls.
Oh, we are here.
Check right stall.
That's scary.
Where is the urinals?
Isn't that what a men's bathroom has?
Why do they get 4 stalls?
And we only, the girlies, get only 3 stalls.
Excuse me.
Check first stall.
Maybe tell her to open them.
Oh, I can try.
Open first stall.
Open last stall.
Oh, she can open.
Oh my gosh, this whole time.
I thought check was, you know...
Was...
Pretty...
I thought it, you know...
I thought we understood the assignment.
Check.
Oh, nevermind.
Open second stall.
Open the second stall.
No!
Oh my God.
Stop.
Men's stalls.
Guys, there is no middle because...
I'll try middle left.
Try stall 2.
Open stall 2.
Wait, where are we?
This isn't stall 2.
Where are we?
This is the last stall.
Oh gosh.
This is stall 4.
Shoot!
Mouth!
Stomach!
Wait, hold on.
Shoot!
Stomach!
Run!
Shoot!
Mouth!
Stomach!
Shoot!
Heal!
Oh my God.
I needed to heal.
Heal!
Help!
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
She's about to die!
Heal!
Run!
I was recover.
Oh my gosh.
I was...
I forgot the word.
I forgot you can't use heal.
Rio!
You know, I feel like this is the one game you guys can't say skill issue to.
I'm not the one shooting.
Voice issue.
I think we have to go back to the women's stalls.
Ladies stalls.
It's the ladies stalls.
Because we have to get the ticket again.
I have to figure out what the auto-fire is.
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
Open stall 1.
Okay, I'll open it.
Open it.
I'm scared.
You have to.
Open stall 2.
Why does she have such trouble with 2?
Which stall was that?
Open stall 2.
2!
Hey, you know, I really am scared.
Don't say anything stupid, you jerk.
What did I say?
Did she think I was trying to kiss her or something?
Open second stall.
Oh my gosh.
Open stall 2.
2!
You know what?
Fine.
That works.
What was it?
Search trash can.
What do you mean?
And then inside the trash can.
Look inside trash can.
No, there's not.
You called her number 2.
Try number 2?
Okay, I'll try number 2.
Autofire.
Wait.
Mat.
What do I say?
Reload.
Shoot.
Number 1.
Special?
Oh there's a sexy pose.
Hold on.
Where?
It's not in there.
Weird.
Ladies stalls.
Oh I passed it.
It was under special.
Wait, where?
Special.
Oh!
In battle.
Autofire.
Okay, cool.
Open stall number 2.
Try open stall.
Open stall 2.
Open stall 3.
Oh yeah, middle stall.
Maybe, maybe.
I'll try it.
Nothing.
Okay.
Okay, no problem.
Open middle stall.
Oh wait, there are 4 stalls here.
I'm blind.
Open third stall.
Open stall number 3.
No!
Stop!
Ladies stalls.
Oh my god, please.
Please listen to me Rio.
Open stall.
Open right stall.
Open middle right stall.
Open second stall.
Stop!
It should be second stall from the left.
Okay.
Ladies stalls.
I'll try again.
Open second stall from the left.
It worked!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, it worked.
Finally.
Then there was something inside!
It was actually worth it!
Oh my goodness, thank you.
There's...
Yeah, grab it.
Oh thank god, it was actually worth my time.
Can I tell her to recover now?
Recover health.
Recover.
I guess not.
Okay, how do I...
Open second stall from right.
Oh it worked!
Oh my gosh.
Thank goodness.
It's so inconsistent.
I know, right?
Please don't get ambushed.
Recover!
Okay, alright.
Shoot!
Auto-fire!
Run!
Auto-fire stomach!
Oh my god.
Stomach!
Keep shooting!
Run!
What do you mean where did it go?
I love auto-fire!
Yeah!
Save point.
Holy moly, where did it go?
Gosh.
You shot it to death, Rio.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Alright, we save.
We did the ladies room.
Have you guys ever seen a ladies room before?
Is that your first time?
Lucky you.
Okey dokey.
To the men's room.
Yuck.
Men's stalls.
Run.
No.
Men's stalls.
I am a lady.
Then you know that the bathrooms are too clean here.
Ladies restrooms are not typically very good.
It was the fourth stall that we got ambushed before, right?
Check closet.
Is it also a number closet?
We are also getting ambushed in here.
Oh that sucks.
Run!
Nice.
Auto-fire!
What did I do?
Mouth!
Stomach!
Auto-fire!
Run!
Alright.
Nice, nice, nice.
Auto-fire!
Stomach!
Mouth!
Auto-fire!
Run!
Mouth!
Oh wait.
Auto-fire!
Run!
No.
I mean mouth.
Auto-fire!
Oh wow.
She did it.
I can't believe it.
It would have only taken two bullets if she actually knew how to aim.
Oh my god.
I love auto-fire.
I'm going to use that the whole game.
Okay.
What was it?
Open stall second from right.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
I'll open it.
That is a ricochet sound.
Yeah!
I need your professional advice.
I'm playing a game and I'm torn.
Do I date the cute girl who spams emoticons in text or the goth girl with her freaky long alien tongue?
I think the alien tongue.
Right?
What kind of emoticons are we talking about?
Are you playing...
Needy Streamer Overload?
Are you playing Needy Streamer Overload?
Open stall second from left.
Was there anything in the first one?
I can't remember.
I don't think so.
Oh, he's got a ticket.
He's got a golden ticket.
He's got a golden ticket to the shutter.
A chip?
He's not going to come alive, is he?
What was it?
Men's wash stands.
Yeah, they're all dressed very dapper in this.
Check mirror.
A mirror?
Check middle mirror.
Shoot middle mirror.
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
029?
Oh, that's it?
029.
I wonder what this number is.
Okay, check trash can.
It's an ordinary trash can.
Even the detail...
This game, despite being so old, is like...
I mean, it's PS2.
There's even...
They have the glass shatter on the sink and everything.
Everything is actually like...
You know, kind of pretty detailed.
Check inside trash can.
Is it empty?
Okay.
Go to save point.
And run.
Run.
She's so...
She's so cautious.
Come on, girl.
Come on.
Oh, she's fine now.
To be fair, I think I'd be pretty scared, too.
Journey you.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Eat the trash can.
I guess if you're desperate, you get lots of fiber from the paper towels, right?
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
What was it?
Ladies' closet.
029 Ladies' stalls.
Go to ladies' stalls.
Takako, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
And Logan, thanks for the five gift.
Go to closet.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We got this.
What's in here?
We got the chip.
That's the one to the shutter.
Wait, no.
The chip is just stuff we're collecting, isn't it?
One...
Zero...
Two...
Nine...
Yay!
Yeah, shoot the ghost.
Shoot it, Rio.
Thank you, Journey.
Thank you.
Open it.
I believe in you.
Is it an actual music box?
I don't know.
Shoot it.
Shoot the music box.
Does it?
I don't know.
Check pendant.
Astronaut?
Wait, it won't let me go over to the next thing.
It won't let me check what the...
Take pendant.
Read note.
There we go.
Eat it.
Is she space superstitious?
What?
Meg?
Oh my god!
Meg!
I'm jogging now.
No, Meg!
That's karma for you, Meg.
Get karma'd.
Play stupid pranks, win stupid prizes.
Save point.
Sorry, I know I'm over-saving.
I just don't want to have to redo any steps, you know what I mean?
Was it family guy, Meg?
Holy crap, Lois.
Meg pranked us with a ghost.
I was doing dishes.
I'm playing Warframe.
I'll date Eleanor with your advice.
She might devour me.
I think it makes her more likeable.
Thanks, Minto.
I got you.
Go to hallway.
At least we know it's not haunted by that person, maybe.
But I just left the room, so it's not haunted anymore.
Go to shutter 5.
No!
Where is that?
Stop.
I'm about to send her across the entire map.
Go to shutter 5.
Rio's all I need.
A little bit of Rio's all I need.
Wait, how does it go?
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Minto is so fun.
A little bit of... Oh, it looks smoky.
I think the place might be on fire.
Oh, where are we?
Go to guest room 5.
We are probably about to get ambushed everybody.
Please remain calm.
Keep your seatbelts fastened until we turn off the overhead light.
I knew it was on fire!
Oh my gosh.
Fire!
Run away!
Right eye.
Red eye.
No.
Auto fire.
I think I have to get that one in the stomach or else it...
Run!
That works too, but...
Auto fire.
I can't see it.
That's your fault!
Stomach!
Spin gun.
What should I do?
Auto fire.
Stomach.
Head.
Auto fire.
You got this.
A little bit more.
There you go.
Six shots.
That's a great question.
Hold on.
I'm checking.
This place is horribly...I hear a fire.
I don't think we should go in there.
I see smoke.
Emergency panel.
I don't think we should go in there.
I think Rio you are going to die from...
I'm in shambles.
I don't think it's only the emergency panel.
Surprise, surprise.
Living area.
Rio is so into having her hands held.
Do you think she is a waffle or pancake gal?
She is a waffler because she wants a little bit more of an aggressive hold.
For those who don't know...
You know when you are hand holding and when you interlock the fingers, it kind of looks like a waffle.
So it's waffling.
And if you have a normal handshake where your palms are against each other, that's called a pancake.
I'm explaining the facts of life.
What am I...
Check glasses.
Do you like my sunglasses?
Wear sunglasses.
There is no need to wreck it.
Why did you take your gun out then?
Rio there is a sun room.
What is this thing?
Is that a book?
Check book.
That looks like hair.
What is that?
Oh it's a wig.
I was right.
Check wig.
This isn't an ordinary wig.
It's more for costume parties.
I was going to say we have a cosplayer.
Wear wig.
Put on the wig?
This isn't the right time for dress up.
Will you wear wigs?
Have you worn wigs?
What is that though?
Check book.
Are you talking about this?
That's not a book.
What do you think that is you guys?
Tablet?
Check tablet.
How am I supposed to understand that?
Ok, we are too advanced for her.
Clip file?
Check file.
Are you talking about this?
I think she wants to wear the wig you guys.
Album?
Check album.
Are you talking about this?
What is it?
News board.
Check news board.
What?
But tablet didn't work?
Live downloads of breaking news.
New item available.
What is it?
Use news board.
Download the new news.
Download.
Read news board.
The station hotel's party just ended a great success?
That news is strange.
Uh oh.
Especially after sending a rescue team.
Um.
Or is it just because our situation hasn't been released to the media yet?
Cover up.
It's a cover up.
Oh my god.
Use sunglasses.
If I were to wear these you wouldn't be able to see my face very well.
That's okay.
You'd look really cool.
Okay.
Uh.
Bed.
I'm scared.
I think it's going to catch on fire.
I think that room is on fire.
I knew it.
Is there some way of putting out a fire?
Bucket.
It's just a bucket.
Yeah, and you fill it with water.
Take bucket.
The bucket is too close to the fire.
Okay.
I can't get it.
Shoot bucket.
Did you see how far it flew?
What is that?
Oh my god.
Wow, I can't believe shooting things actually works.
Shoot fire extinguisher.
Yeah.
Shoot it.
I did it.
A miracle.
Are you okay?
Oh god.
We killed Rio.
Do you think Rio would survive Metal Gear Solid?
I think she would love it because of the codec.
Yeah, that was so easy.
Nice.
Hold on, we are not done in here.
Check bed.
Yeah, your favorite spot baby girl.
There is a ticket.
Oh, there is a person.
Maybe don't check her leg.
Um, corpse or coat.
Yeah.
I didn't even notice the dead lady.
Bathrobe.
Um, check bathrobe.
Yeah.
Yes there is.
Search bathrobe.
Bathrobe.
Bathrobe pocket.
Check bathrobe pocket.
Check pocket.
The bathrobe.
What else?
What do we say?
Oh.
Shoot bathrobe.
Then why do you get into position?
Why do you tease me?
You go through all the effort of looking like you are about to do it.
But you never... What the heck?
Um, check pocket.
Huh?
Of what?
Check bathrobe pocket.
It's the hotel.
There is nothing strange about it.
Inside bathrobe.
The bathrobe?
I don't need that.
Oh my gosh.
At least we got a different answer.
I tried search pocket.
Search pocket.
No!
Stop.
Bed.
I feel so...
I feel too much in command.
I feel naughty.
Like stop bed.
Oh gosh.
Move bathrobe.
Search bathrobe.
I don't know what to say.
Check inside bathrobe.
Check inside.
Inspect bathrobe.
Oh my gosh.
Check card maybe.
Check card.
Oh my gosh.
Yes.
Take card.
Take card in pocket.
That's not what I said.
Card in pocket.
The bathrobe.
Oh gosh.
Ticket maybe.
Pick up ticket.
I've said check bathrobe pocket.
I'll try.
Check bathrobe pocket.
That's what she says every time.
She says that every time.
Try using colors.
That's a good idea.
Yellow card.
Throw what?
What did she just say?
Yellow card.
Yellow ticket.
She wanted me to throw a pillow.
I don't know.
I really don't know what to say.
I'm so... I don't know.
She has brain damage from the smoke inhalation.
And the fire extinguisher.
You are slow with thinking.
Cognitive.
Function.
Breast pocket.
Breast pocket of bathrobe.
I don't know.
I don't know how
to...
Pick up bathrobe.
Yes!
Check ticket.
Check...
What did I say?
Check card.
Yes!
Please take it.
Take card.
No!
Stop.
Bed.
Run.
Oh my god.
You guys keep sending me variations, but I've tried them.
Game facts says check pocket of bathrobe.
That's what I said though.
I said that.
I'll try.
Check pocket of bathrobe.
See?
She says that every time.
Oh my gosh.
Fukuro!
Amy, that was my birthday so I figured I'd share the happiness with my own.
It seems you have plenty of screaming in your game.
That's okay.
I can sing.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Fukuro.
Thank you for the HAKODONA!
Thank you!
Okay.
What was it say?
They said that game facts... Let me see if I can try it.
Check pocket of bathrobe.
I tried it though.
I tried it.
Oh...
Check pocket of bathrobe.
No!
Fine.
You know what?
We'll give her a break.
We'll give her a break from the bathrobe.
Oh gosh.
That scared me.
This guy is sick popular.
This is the one.
Pat head.
This guy is sick pompadour.
I can't.
Yes ma'am.
Search wig.
No!
Stop!
Bathroom.
Search corpse hair.
Rude.
He doesn't look that old.
He just looks a little grey.
He's obviously a cosplayer.
It's Homestuck.
Don't be so rude.
Oh gosh.
Check sink.
Take mobile phone.
Why does he have it then?
Use mobile phone.
They just throw the sandwich and they go after that?
Probably.
Take off wig.
I think I can't say wig you guys.
Stop.
I think she thinks... I don't know.
I think she's thinking something else when I say wig.
Bathroom.
Oh my gosh.
Look under hair.
No.
Check hair.
Yeah.
Yes.
It's not what I asked.
Search corpse hair.
But it's shiny.
Oh gosh.
This is the bed all over again.
Head.
I
can't say wig you guys.
Search head.
Remove hair.
Head.
Alcohol and anger.
Take hair.
You know what?
Fine.
We'll just go back and forth.
This room is torturous.
Okay.
We are back here.
What was it that the GameFAQ said?
Do a pose in front of the dead guy.
Do a sexy pose.
She doesn't want to have a girly fun sleep over time.
She doesn't want to get stripped down into her underwear and throw a pillow and have the feathers go everywhere.
And she's just giggling and laughing in her underwear while the feathers just cover her body and cover the air.
And she's just having a giggly time.
She doesn't want to do anything fun.
Oh wait.
I read that.
Thank you Coffin though.
Red side welcome to membership.
GameFAQ says check bathrobe and then check pocket of bathrobe.
Okay.
Check bathrobe.
Check pocket of bathrobe.
That's every time.
Okay.
We are back here.
Time to try and get this guy again.
Oh yeah.
Check behind corpse.
Check behind head.
I can't.
I'm stuck in a loop.
Check bathrobe pocket.
The bathroom.
Okay.
It's fine because we do have something we need to do in here.
We just don't know how to do it either.
What's the GameFAQ say for this one?
What does the GameFAQ say?
You're awfully slow with instructions.
I'm going to google it myself.
Hold on.
Lifeline.
Maybe making a statement helps?
Is that how the game works?
I can't remember.
It's check wig?
No.
Check wig.
Stop!
Oh look under wig.
Okay.
Bathroom.
Let's try that.
Look under wig.
Sorry.
Yes!
Oh my god yes!
Oh my god!
We got one!
Stop!
Seashells by the seashore.
No way!
No!
Oh okay.
Okay.
Yes!
Let's start with an easy one.
That's an easy one?
She's warming up.
Oh my god.
I can't remember all this.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
What?
She stood on a balcony inexplicably mimicking him.
Hiccuping him.
What the hell?
We went through so much trouble to get that.
What was it?
She inexplicably hiccuped on him on the balcony where he was inexplicably...
I don't remember.
The Seashells command lets you heal every time you complete three tongue twisters.
The only way to heal outside of the limited capsules.
The game never tells you this.
No way.
Wait seriously?
Hold on.
Seashells.
Special.
Oh.
She...
She sells.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I got this you guys.
I got this.
Thank you Tom!
Oh my god.
Yes.
Okay.
Pick up six pick up sticks quickly.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh easy, easy.
What?
There is more to it?
She sells seashells on the seashore.
She sells seashells.
She is short.
No!
There is more!
Hold on.
I am googling this.
Lifeline tongue twisters.
I can't remember them.
They are too long.
No!
Okay, hold on.
Where are the tongue twisters?
Oh, she sells.
Minigames.
I can't remember them.
Please.
Complete the phrase.
No, no, no.
She sells.
Okay, okay.
I have them written down.
Okay.
Oh, yes.
Oh my god, there is really...
Okay.
Rubber baby buggy bumpers.
Yeah.
Okay.
I have it written down.
A noise annoys an oyster, but a noisy noise annoys an oyster more.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I am really good at this.
Oh!
Okay.
I got it written.
Good.
Heal.
Thanks for the entertainment.
Oh my gosh, it really healed.
It really worked.
Okay, I'm going to have those on standby.
Oh my god.
Okay, now Rio, bed.
Oh yeah, baby girl.
I am an enunciating queen.
Check, bathrobe, pocket.
Are you talking about this?
Check the pocket of the bathrobe.
There is something inside.
It's a chip.
That worked.
Oh my god.
Finally, we did everything in here.
Oh wait.
There is a save point.
Oh thank god.
Check dresser.
Yeah, I'll save the game.
Don't worry.
I'll save the game.
Okay.
Save point.
The save point.
Okay.
Yeah, the low-pitched voice worked.
It's discriminatory against my voice.
It's discriminating.
We got 9 chips.
My voice recognition has gone down significantly.
It's gone down so much.
Okay.
She's traumatized on the ground.
Okay, leave room.
Okay, bye bye.
Run.
You did it.
I did it.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
What?
What if... What if I took my girlfriend up into space to like...
To kill her off.
In like some elaborate... Like I was gonna put her into the air chute and send her out into space.
And I'm just like, oh great.
My girlfriend is safe.
We all flew up here.
Operator.
What should I do?
I guess we can't go to shutter 8.
It doesn't let us.
Are we going to the moon suite?
Oh my gosh.
Butts everywhere.
Go to shutter 6.
Shutter 6.
Okay.
Yeah.
Run.
Oh.
Yes.
I like how she's like, if you find my boyfriend...
What did you say?
Oh my gosh.
Middle eye.
Oh.
Run.
Okay, we wait for it to turn right.
Right eye.
Middle eye.
Left eye.
Auto fire.
Reload.
I didn't realize that...
Red eye.
Auto fire.
Please reload your aim.
Oh.
Run.
Body?
Body.
Mouth.
Auto aim.
I mean...
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Oh no.
Mouth.
Tail.
I don't know.
Body.
Oh my gosh.
Run!
Why did you stop there?
Tail.
Shoot.
Auto fire.
Tail.
Oh my gosh.
Run.
Yes.
Nice, nice, nice.
Tail.
Okay.
I was trying.
Oh my gosh.
Where are we going?
Shutter 6.
Run.
Oh yeah.
We got to do the cells.
We got to do more tongue twisters.
Here we go.
That's so good.
Thank you Tom.
Oh my gosh.
For teaching me about that.
We'll save so much health.
Okay.
Yeah.
Where is...
Where is here?
What was that?
What's that?
Is this the moon suite?
We are going to open it up and we are going to be flashed with bare flesh.
Wait.
I didn't say you could go in there.
Wait a second.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
What am I supposed to see?
Oh look at her.
She looks so cool.
Is this a hidden object game?
What am I...
What am I supposed to be seeing?
Oh!
Stop!
Person!
What?
Human!
What was I supposed to tell her?
I told her to stop.
I told her...
That's good.
About time.
Rescue team.
That's wonderful.
You are supposed to say turn right?
Okay.
That's okay.
Yeah, so true.
Good point.
Oh no!
Why didn't you say that sooner?
I have an operator backing me up.
He'll open it for us.
You can do it, right?
Why can't you?
It's just a shutter.
Don't worry, I know you can do it.
He says he can.
You definitely lied.
I won't board the shuttle.
He's going down with the ship.
Listen operator.
I told you that I need proper guidance.
The way things are going, I fear for my future.
Your future?
That's so dramatic.
Let's search this room.
I love the music in here.
It's so good.
I'm afraid for my future.
Honestly, you're safe.
Rio, that's so relatable.
Oh no!
I wanted to search in there.
Aw man.
Okay.
What is that?
There's a room on the other side of the hall.
Oh wait, maybe not a room.
Maybe we can't go in there.
There was a room on the other side too, but it doesn't have a label.
Like on the other side of shutter 6, you see it?
Let's play.
What is it?
Sorry!
Seashells!
Sea...Seashells?
Seashells.
What?
No way!
Oh, she sells.
What?
No!
She sells.
Uh oh.
She won't let me do it, you guys.
I'm gonna go back to guest room 5.
Guest room 5.
I'm gonna go save.
Actually, we don't really need...
Well, run.
I was gonna say we don't really need to save, but you know what?
It's actually fine.
Is there a cool town?
I think it's consultation first.
I don't think so.
Hold on.
Oh gosh, I keep...
You're welcome.
Ok.
She sells.
There we go.
Oh yeah.
Ok.
I'm getting my thing pulled up.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
Oh yeah.
We're healing.
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't Fuzzy Wuzzy.
I know this one!
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't Fuzzy Wuzzy.
Not bad.
I like that one.
Ok, your turn.
How many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
I did.
You're welcome.
Oh, it didn't heal everything.
She sells...
One more, one more.
Yes.
Let's start with an easy one.
Okay, give me what I haven't done before.
Pick up six pick up sticks quickly.
Okay,
your turn.
Awesome.
Repeat after me.
Don't be a pepper.
I saw Esau kissing Kate.
Kate saw I saw Esau.
Esau saw that I saw Kate and Kate saw I saw Esau.
This is not English.
Okay, your turn.
What?
I saw Esau kissing Kate.
Kate saw I saw Esau.
Esau saw that I saw Kate and Kate saw I saw Esau.
What?
What are you talking about?
I read it straight from the thing.
I saw... who... first... what?
This is not real.
I got robbed for real.
I got robbed.
Okay, never mind.
Save point.
I give up.
Your complaining got registered.
No, it didn't.
I saw Esau kissing Kate.
Kate saw I saw Esau.
Esau saw that I saw Kate and Kate saw I saw Esau.
That's just... that is not English.
Those are not real words.
That's not real English.
Call her a doody head.
I will.
Yeah, you saw a lot.
Esau is supposed to be a name of a person, but like... who hates their child to name them Esau?
Doody head.
Poopy.
Poop.
Leave room.
Esau, Esau.
Esau's mom.
They spell it on GameFAQs as E-S-A-W.
So it's like literally saw, but with... but with E in front of it.
Where should I go?
Maybe that's why it looks so weird to me.
Like, yeah, like E-girl, but yeah, but Esau.
Yeah, exactly.
So maybe that's why I didn't register it as a name.
Esau, Esau, Esau, Esau.
Esau, Esau, Esau, Esau, Esau.
Esau, Esau.
Go to elevator hall.
Run.
Like, like your life depends on it.
Look at her.
I think she picked up a little bit of speed.
See, there is a door down there.
Enemy has...
Run!
Oh no.
Oh gosh.
Head!
Stomach!
Mouth!
Mouth.
Oh!
Run!
Oh no.
Okay.
Inner mouth!
Shoot!
Auto...
Auto shoot!
Oh no, not body.
Inner mouth!
Let's go.
Number two, inner mouth.
Where are we?
Oh, elevator hall.
Yeah, exactly.
That's where we were going.
Yeah.
I can't, I'm here and all that.
That's a great question.
Uh...
I guess we go...
Receiving point.
Run!
Inner mouth!
No, no.
Actually, oh that works.
Inner mouth!
Auto fire!
No, inner mouth!
Oh my gosh.
No!
Inner
mouth!
Dodge!
Inner mouth!
Inner
mouth!
Recover!
Oh my god.
Dodge!
Dodge left!
No!
That's not even...
Run!
Left eye!
Dodge right!
No!
Oh, I'm about to die!
Oh my gosh.
Dodge left and she moves, she's like turn right!
That's not even the way that I said!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna do another tongue twister.
She sells.
Yep.
Here we go, okay.
So you wanna play tongue twister with me?
I like the way she breaks her neck when I ask her that.
Yep.
So you wanna play tongue twister with me?
Yes.
Let's start with an easy one.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
Okay.
Okay, your turn.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
Good!
Repeat after me.
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't Fuzzy Wuzzy.
Okay, your turn.
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't Fuzzy Wuzzy.
Good!
Yeah!
Repeat after me.
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
Okay.
We always got the Peter Piper peppers!
Okay, um... save point.
No, save point.
Save point.
We got it.
We got, we got.
Okay, I'm just gonna save so that she's full health.
Holy moly.
Okay, let's go.
She wants you bad.
She wants me bad, bad.
But can you blame her?
You know, look at her.
She's so... desperate.
Leave room.
Run.
I'm so commanding.
She probably just has fallen for me with how... stern I am, you know?
I'm just so like... I'm like, run, Maria.
Go to the elevator hall.
Go... oh.
Oh yeah.
Run.
Yes.
You have a girlfriend though?
I mean, she can't help her feelings for me.
You know?
She can't help it.
Alright, let's get ambushed, baby!
Yeah!
Enemy.
Enemy has been spotted.
Run.
Stomach.
Alright, inner mouth.
Run.
Inner mouth.
Auto fire.
No, inner mouth.
Inner mouth.
Auto fire.
Run.
Rio, you did not get a single hit?
Auto fire.
Oh my god.
Reload.
Rio.
Run.
Oh... my god.
Oh.
The eye is a weak spot when it rears up.
Oh, really?
I thought just the inner mouth was the...
was the... weak point.
Good to know.
Okay.
Elevator hall.
The elevator hall.
Okay.
The audacity of missing every shot then saying that was easy.
Let's check... we went to the...
I think actually we just get ambushed in this room.
So it doesn't really matter where we go, huh?
Okay.
Receiving port.
The receiving port.
Okay.
Run.
Eye.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Inner mouth.
Back.
She's so slow to dodge.
Inner mouth.
Yes.
Target front.
Number
two.
Right eye.
Run.
Left.
Let's move on.
Where?
Inner mouth.
The receiving port is up ahead.
Receiving port.
The receiving port.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What?
Did you not get ambushed?
Okay.
It's kind of nice, the silence, right?
Tell the operator to open the shutter right now.
Open the shutter.
Right button.
Oh, that's not what I said.
Power panel.
She's so rude.
Left power panel.
Okay.
I'll do it.
She's so rude.
Oh, okay.
That's all I gotta do.
I thought we...
I didn't realize...
Oh yeah, play the tongue twister.
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
Oh wait, no.
Our health is actually pretty good.
Oh, oh, oh.
Uh oh.
I think something bad is gonna happen when I do this.
I have a feeling.
It's a little bad.
Okay, maybe we're okay.
No, I think they're dead.
Everybody is dead but me!
Dear.
Uh oh.
Yeah, this does scream possibly, right?
What?
No!
Dear.
No, dear!
Sir, I can't let you do that.
There's no urgency.
Maybe two or three max?
Sir, I can't let you do that.
More for me.
Okay.
Oh, okay, it would help if you hit...
Pick it back up?
What do you mean?
You spoke with such confidence!
Oh my god!
He didn't even land a single hit!
He didn't land a single hit!
He was so confident!
We're humans!
Oh, just kidding.
Rescue team?
Yeah!
I don't have to play the game anymore!
Yes sir!
Captain Yatsumeda, sir.
The shuttle terminal has been destroyed.
So we had to break through the ceiling.
That delayed our arrival.
It couldn't be helped.
I mean...
I don't think anyone knew what was going to happen.
Okay.
Yes sir.
Wait, but my girlfriend...
I also like how the butler's bow tie looks like candy.
Sneaking suit.
Oh my gosh, bodysuit!
Oh!
Peek!
Peek and look around the box.
Look around box.
Check box.
Search box.
Move box.
Please!
Walk out from box!
Rio!
Walk out from box.
Check box.
Move box.
Walk from box.
Why was that scene so long for no reason?
Just to tease me.
Just a box.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
She has the important information.
Okay.
I'm saying okay.
I'm done.
Say yes ma'am.
Yes ma'am.
Naomi.
Beg.
What?
We are in the big leagues now.
Wow.
We were so robbed.
That was the table where she kept saying no.
Really?
No way.
Her guns!
Her guns are useless!
We're under attack by some invincible alien!
We are under attack by some...
I'm not the biggest pervert here.
We are under attack by some invincible monster.
What is happening?
What is this camera angle?
What is this supposed to mean?
Is it a giant spider?
Just use a flamethrower.
No sir!
But I'm an operator.
Yeah.
Oh where the heck are we?
Nice view!
Oh my god!
Wait this sneaking suit is genius!
Do you see the panties with the cut out pants?
Holy moly!
Moly, moly, moly, moly.
Control staff quarters.
Run.
Those were...wow!
Okay.
That was great!
What a design!
That's so good.
Sexy.
Uh oh.
Zombies.
The aliens are invisible though sometimes.
Wow this is a really big room.
Save point.
There's candy!
Oh wow!
Oh no this room.
Uh oh.
What do you mean by that?
That always scares me when you guys say things like that.
Yay!
Voice recognition average is...
Yeah I was going to say our average used to be 9000 and now it's at 6000.
Check table.
Yup.
I thought you have darn wigs and bathrobes.
I feel like we spent most of the time today.
Candy!
Eat candy.
No way.
Oh!
It's orange.
Eat candy.
Which flavor is this one?
It's yellow.
It's pretty sweet.
Eat candy.
Mint!
Watermelon?
Girl dinner?
Candy jar.
Eat green candy.
Is she actually going to eat the green candy?
Oh she's colorblind.
Purple.
Great munching noises Minto.
Thank you.
It's great.
How should I say about... candy container.
Ah...
Jar.
What?
No!
Stop!
Who's Jonathan?
Check table.
Box maybe?
Maybe...
Candy box.
She isn't real.
She likes watermelon candy.
What's wrong with the watermelon candy?
Actually... oh my gosh.
You guys know... if you know... if you have extra gum in your country.
You guys know the watermelon extra gum?
Hold on.
Let me make sure that's the right one.
Yeah!
Extra... the sweet watermelon is so good.
If you can ever get the extra gum watermelon flavor.
It's so yummy!
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
The lemonade one though?
I've never had that one.
Actually...
Oh gosh.
What do I say to this thing?
Jar.
Okay.
Stop.
What else is in here?
Galley?
Galley.
What the hell is that?
Oh!
Check top shelf.
And... look behind dinnerware.
The jelly kind.
Yippee!
Okay.
Check second shelf.
The second floor?
No, no.
Stop.
Galley.
Why is it sparkling on the tissues?
Check tissues.
Yes there is.
It's right there.
What is that?
Middle shelf.
Sorry for overstepping my bounds.
Since I won't be able to tune in live, I just want to say for tomorrow.
When in doubt, make more villagers.
Thank you.
Coffee bean.
Make coffee.
I am.
Look next to juice.
Okay, go next to juice.
Wax paper?
Wax paper.
Take it.
What's there?
Or is it a note?
Oh my gosh.
Check coffee pot.
No.
Check coffee maker.
Okay.
Oh, that's it.
Check bottom shelf.
We learned strafe, but she's so slow.
Eat it.
Eat...
Eat... oh wait.
Eat donut.
Rio,
you need the calories right now.
Eat ham.
Eat cheese.
Okay.
She's so picky.
Eat bread.
Oh my gosh.
I think Rio is like...
Actually insufferable.
Too crusty.
I don't like cheese.
Too many calories.
No ham.
No time for ham.
Too crunchy.
I don't like cheese.
More macaroni.
She really is Goldilocks.
Oh my gosh, Rio.
Nothing.
You don't want anything.
You're not thirsty.
You're not hungry.
She would rather eat pure sugar off the table.
She would rather eat the candy from the table than a donut, which is actual calories.
I know it's sugar calories, but you're the one running around and fighting aliens.
Table.
Girl dinner.
Yeah, I saw someone say middle.
Middle of table.
Yes.
It was a trick.
I think we gotta ditch this girl.
I can't believe I'm saying this, but I think Naomi might be better.
We don't even know her, but...
In a world where Naomi is better than any other character.
A jar of candy.
It's a big jar.
No, I don't mean Naomi Hunter.
Don't get it twisted.
No, no, no.
We have our girlfriend Naomi in this game, everybody.
Not Naomi Hunter.
No, no, no.
Lockers.
I'm gonna lock her up in the lockers.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Oh my god.
No!
Mouth.
Enemy three.
How is it that you miss every freaking shot?
Run!
Mouth.
Enemy two.
Run.
Middle eye.
Number two.
Mouth.
Head.
Enemy two.
Low kick.
If she would just hit.
Auto fire.
Mouth.
Oh my god.
Run.
Enemy one.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Run.
Oh my god.
Auto fire.
Stomach.
Run.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Reload.
This is so painful man.
This is so painful.
Run.
Oh my god.
Rio, please.
You can't.
You don't even aim.
Enemy two.
Stomach.
She is not close enough.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Enemy three.
Run.
Reload.
I'm playing musical pairs with this thing.
Straight.
That didn't do it.
Move left.
Stomach.
Auto fire.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Auto fire.
What do you mean no?
You need to hit it.
Stomach.
Auto fire.
Right.
Run.
No.
Stomach.
Okay.
Save point.
Makes a lot of sense she can't aim.
That's a heckin O-I-C-W.
She is hip firing.
Thing weighs 20 pounds.
Okay, but what about when she was using her pistol earlier?
That doesn't...She was just as bad before.
She was just as bad before.
It takes talent to shoot a donut around the target.
Oh my god.
You would see her shoot and it would be like...
And every single one would just circle around the dang worm.
Oh my gosh.
Lockers.
Run.
Right locker.
Wait, Jonathan.
Left locker.
I think I can open these, right?
Please enter the passcode.
No!
Can I do this one?
Oh no.
They both require...Okay.
What else is in here?
Shower room.
There is a phone.
Phone.
Oops, I pressed the wrong button.
No.
Stop.
Shower room.
That is a phone, right?
That's not the shower, right?
Shower head?
I thought it was a phone.
Bottle.
Stop.
Shower room.
Run.
Where are you going?
Stop.
Shower room.
Where was she going?
She said shower room.
Run.
Shampoo.
Stop.
Shower room.
Shampoo.
Soap!
That's not what I said.
Shelf?
Shelf.
Check bottle.
Shower room.
It's a health pack.
Check behind bottle.
Stop.
Shower room.
Where is she going?
I'm so curious.
Run.
Where is she going?
What shower room...oh.
Rio...Zoolander over here?
Shower room.
Run.
I want the health.
I feel like I'm fighting with this game most of the time.
Shampoo.
I tried that.
Oh it worked.
Oh my gosh.
Thank goodness.
I tried shampoo and it said...
She said Jonathan's room.
Is that a washing machine in here?
That's weird.
Ah...
Storage area.
This is a real fighting game.
Can you imagine a fighting game where you actually have to do this?
It's just like X, Y, Z, Z, X, Y, X...
Are you kidding me?
Run.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Hey.
Run away.
Do I have to shoot them in order?
That's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to shoot them like 1, 2, 3, you know?
Escape?
Run.
Run away.
Run left.
Run.
Oh my god.
Strength.
This is what strength does you guys.
You guys have told me to do it the last time and that's what it did.
Run away.
Oh from what you're targeting.
4, 5, 6.
Enemy 3.
Run.
I thought it just meant run in general.
Enemy 1.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Ok.
Mouth.
Girl!
Move right.
Move right...oh move left.
Walk.
Enemy 3.
Aim.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Move right.
Ok.
Nice, nice, nice.
Move right.
Save point.
Run.
Oh wait, actually...
I was going to heal, but we'll finish.
Oh my god.
I literally was banging my head on my microphone.
The fact that she just runs when I try to get her into position.
Yeah, you sit there and contemplate your actions Rio.
Oh yeah.
Storage area.
Run.
What's here?
Candy.
Oh a note.
Read note.
Clean.
This isn't the right time.
Read note.
Clean.
This isn't the right time.
Box.
Cardboard box?
Which one do you mean?
Check topped cardboard...
What should I check?
Sorry.
Check candy box.
This says fruit flavored candy on it.
This didn't come from the hotel.
Yet there's so much of it.
Open candy box.
It's a cardboard box full of candies.
Ok.
No shower time?
I mean we can go back in.
Check hotel box.
Are you talking about this?
Check invoice.
It's an invoice addressed to Jonathan.
Jonathan?
Wow.
He ordered an amazing amount of fruit candies.
He loves candy.
Wait.
Can I read it?
Oh.
For Mr. Jonathan Turner, please remit payment for the 20 cases of fruit candy that you had ordered.
Read invoice.
It's an invoice addressed to Jonathan.
Check vacuum.
Are you talking about this?
Check vacuum cleaner.
It's the hotel's vacuum cleaner.
It's really useful for cleaning.
Use vacuum cleaner.
You want me to clean?
Huh.
A neat freak.
Not too cool considering what's going on around us.
What do you mean not too cool?
Open bright box.
There are cardboard boxes everywhere.
Can you be a little more specific?
Check right box.
There are cardboard boxes everywhere.
Can you be a little more specific?
I don't understand how this is important.
Maybe the 20?
Check the invoice.
I did.
I read it.
I already did.
Write most.
Oh yeah, maybe color.
Try... wait.
No, no, no.
Stop.
Storage...
Storage area.
I keep wanting to say box.
Shoot box?
Shoot box.
Storage area.
Okay.
Check white box.
This cardboard box contains hotel supplies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I guess they are storing it here temporarily in the staff quarters.
Okay.
Open white box.
It's a cardboard box that contains supplies.
Check brown box.
This is a cardboard box containing office supplies.
Office supplies.
Stuff like pens and paper.
It has nothing to do with us.
Oh.
Okay.
She has x-ray vision.
Truly.
Alright.
Second floor.
Hide in box.
Run.
Yes.
What's this?
Oh!
Jonathan's room!
Balcony.
Why is she just running around in circles?
Trash can.
It's just a trash can.
There's nothing strange about it.
Check trash can.
It's just a trash can.
Search trash can.
Plant.
It's an ordinary house plant.
But all the plants in the station are often studied to obtain data.
Search plant.
It's an ordinary house plant.
But all the plants in the station are often studied to obtain data.
Check under couch.
Under the bench?
Bench.
Sure.
What could it be?
These are the codes!
That thing.
Yes.
Pick it up.
There's a formula written on this.
A formula?
It might be useful for something.
I'll take it.
Okay.
A formula.
A formula?
What?
Alan's reference kit?
No.
Scientific document?
Document filled with scientific formulas.
What kind of... are we...
That's so vague.
Is it like...
Like mixing a potion formula?
She is so...
Jonathan's room.
Yes.
Is Jonathan in there?
Jonathan?
Voice lock?
What do I say?
This is a message for Jonathan Turner.
Jonathan T.
Hi, I'm Jonathan, and this is my room.
I don't know who you are, but if you want to enter my room, you have to answer this question.
You see, there's something that I've been secretly collecting.
Secretly?
Okay, are you ready?
Speak your answer into the mic.
Something that he's collecting.
What's he talking about?
I'll defer to you.
Why me?
Fruit candy.
Maybe it was a bit too tough.
What?
A hint, huh?
Food.
I'm not going to tell you anymore.
Candy.
I don't have the slightest idea.
Let me do it.
Maybe there are hints to be found in this room.
Rio is so slow.
Rio, Rio, Rio, Rio.
This is a message for Jonathan Turner.
Hey guys, I'm Jonathan.
Can you identify what I collect?
Do you want to get into my room?
Are you ready?
Say your answer into the mic.
Okay.
He said he was collecting something you eat.
Think about it.
I know.
Candy.
Maybe it was a bit too tough.
A hint, huh?
What do I say?
Food.
I'm not going to tell you anymore.
I don't have the slightest idea.
Maybe there are hints to be found in this room.
I said fruit candy the first time, you guys.
I'll try it again.
This is a message for Jonathan Turner.
Can you identify what I collect?
I'll watch the rest in archive.
Thanks for the fun.
Thank you.
Say your answer into the mic.
He said he was collecting something you eat.
Think about it.
What's Richard's?
Is that like a type of fruit candy?
Fruit candy.
Maybe it was a bit too tough.
A hint, huh?
Food.
I'm not going to tell you anymore.
I don't have the slightest idea.
Maybe there are hints to be found in this room.
This is a message for Jonathan Turner.
Can you identify what I collect?
Are you ready?
Say your answer into the mic.
He said he was collecting something you eat.
Think about it.
Fruit candy.
Maybe it was a bit too tough.
A hint, huh?
Food.
I'm not going to tell you anymore.
I don't have the slightest idea.
Maybe there are hints to be found in this room.
I'm going to Gustav's room.
Gustav's room.
What?
I don't know.
Fruit candy.
Oh no!
Disengage the lock.
Read note.
Leave the room?
No!
Yes.
Gustav's room.
Leave the room?
No!
Gustav's room.
Jonathan's room.
I'm going...
I'm going mental here, you guys.
I can't do this.
Gustav's room.
Where did you hear balcony?
I keep losing Wi-Fi.
What happened for the AI to say his viewers are reacting to a streamer named Jonathan in interaction with his chat?
Specifically collecting fruit flavored candy.
Fruit candy.
What kind of food is not out in the open?
But he has an invoice of fruit candy.
There was so much food.
There was ham.
There was donuts.
He doesn't collect that.
Imagine being a speedrunner for this game.
I think if you're a speedrunner, you have to use like a text-to-speech, you know?
You have to use text-to-speech.
This has to be the worst idea for video game controls.
No!
Peter, welcome to membership!
Did you try saying fruit flavored candy?
Let's try that.
Jonathan's room.
You have a soundboard?
Maybe, yeah.
Fruit flavored candy.
Let's try that.
This is a message for Jonathan Turner.
Can you identify what I collect?
That is a task at that point.
Say your answer into the mic.
Okay.
He said he was collecting something you eat.
Think about it.
Fruit flavored candy.
Maybe it was a bit too tough.
A hint, huh?
Food.
I'm not going to tell you anymore.
Um...
I don't have the slightest idea.
Maybe there are hints to be found in this room.
I did try just candy.
Uh...
I don't think my volume...
I don't actually...
Can I fix my...
I don't think there's a way to fix my volume...
If it's low.
Like, there's no options.
I guess you're stumped too, Operator.
Gustav's room.
The balcony.
Okay.
Gustav's room.
Yes.
I am stopped.
Gustav's room.
The balcony.
Gustav...Gustav's room!
Leave the room?
Stop!
And then she tries to be cheeky with me.
I can't with this woman!
There's a reason she told you what flavor each piece was.
Gustav!
Yes?
Where are you going?
Where is she going?
I'm just...
I guess we'll see.
Where is she going?
We're letting her cook.
Rio has obtained sentience.
Never...Oh, nevermind.
I spoke too soon.
Control staff quarters.
Yes.
Okay.
I'm gonna not say...
I'm not gonna say room because she keeps thinking I say leave room, I think.
You know?
Gustav.
Gustav!
Oh my god!
Run.
Yes.
Disengage the lock.
Oh, you'll read that note first.
Check note.
The balcony.
Okay.
No, please.
Stop.
Yes.
Gustav.
I am stopped.
Why would they name him this?
Why couldn't he be like Jeremy or something?
Why couldn't he be like David, Blake...
Henry!
Hold on, Rio.
Mommy is having a mental break, please.
I need a sip.
Shut up!
Actually, what was I going to do?
Oh, she sells.
I really don't, but I will.
Yes.
Okay.
Around the rugged rocks, the ragged rascal ran.
Awesome.
Okay.
Did I get this one wrong before?
A noise annoys an oyster, but a noisy noise annoys an oyster more.
Thanks, baby!
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
Okay, your turn.
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
Awesome.
Yeah, Brandon!
Thanks for the vibe, Ethan.
I need you to listen to me, Brio.
I really need you to listen to me.
Gustav's room.
I can't...
Strawberry candy?
Okay.
Strawberry candy.
Okay!
Thank you for your backstaging, everybody.
Inappropriate time to...
Oh my god!
Why does he collect these?
What?
Bottle.
It looks like pills.
Pills here.
Is he okay?
Jar of candy.
The slow...
Is that why there were no pink ones?
I didn't notice that.
Eat candy.
Check computer.
Control staff only.
The registry's top page is displayed.
Hotel regulations.
Waiting room usage restrictions.
Monitor camera expansion program.
Adds night vision mode to standard monitor cameras.
Can I do that?
Security camera upgrade feature.
Why?
Oh, I have to download this.
Let's see.
Oh, I have to do work.
Sorry.
This should work without much fuss.
I'm so used to someone else telling me what to do.
I'm turning my brain off.
Alright!
Yay!
We got an upgrade!
Hacking.
Infrared ray sensitivity upgrade.
Install the latest generation of infrared monitor systems to see clearly under zero light conditions.
Do you think she'll also understand me better?
Is there anything in here?
Card.
Yellow card.
Yes ma'am.
What is that?
Oh shoot.
Yellow card.
Yeah.
What is that?
ID card?
Take ID card.
But he's dead.
Oh, no he's not.
Bed.
Oh wow.
It's the one time she doesn't want to go to the bed.
Alright guys.
Leave room.
Yes.
Okay.
Gustav.
Guys,
I don't know how to do this.
I don't know how.
Gustav.
Just let her go.
If she loves you, she'll come back.
Take a shower.
Yes.
Why do you remember that Rio?
Why do you remember that?
Walk forward.
Walk right.
Check room.
Okay, we'll try that.
Second floor.
We'll try it.
Actually, hold on.
Save panel.
Save point.
Yeah, yeah.
Run.
What?
Save point.
Run.
Since we got to Jonathan's room, let's save real quick.
How long have I been in here?
How long?
Oh
gosh.
No.
Okay, Gustav.
I can try.
Gustav.
Second floor.
Run.
Gustav.
I think I tried that too.
Here I go.
Scream my lungs out and try to get you to listen to me.
Rio, please.
Move right.
Turn around.
Stop.
The one time.
The one time I said stop and she...
Check room.
No!
Stop!
Second floor.
Check room.
That's what I did.
That's what you told me to do and I did it.
Turn around.
Every now and then I feel a little bit...
And you're never coming around.
Turn around.
Every now and then I feel a little bit tired.
Listening to the sound of my turn around.
Every now and then I don't want to go into the room anymore.
Turn around.
A little bit terrified and then I see the look in your eyes.
Bright eyes.
Every now and then I fall apart.
And I need you now tonight.
And I need you more than ever.
And if you only listen to me, Rio.
Gustav's room.
I think Rio is discriminating against him.
I think she wants to believe he doesn't exist.
Eleven, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Gustav's room.
Don't shrug!
Don't shrug at me.
Don't do this.
Gustav's room.
What should I move?
No.
Room.
What should I move?
I don't know what to do, you guys.
Gustav!
Don't shrug!
Gustav's room.
Gustav!
No!
Stop.
Turn right.
What?
Oh my God.
Stop.
Please.
Oh my God.
I'm seeing red.
No!
Stop.
Stop!
Service staff quarters.
I don't care anymore.
Run.
Gustav.
Gustav's room.
She doesn't listen to anything, you guys.
She doesn't listen to anything.
Gustav.
Gustiv.
Shoot yourself.
One of them is me, Rio.
One of them is me.
You understood that, huh?
You understood that, huh Rio?
Johnny's room.
What?
Where are we going?
Ok, we are going on an adventure everybody.
To a mysterious location.
Wherever Rio... She's getting sentient.
What was happening?
Sounds like a helicopter.
What is that?
Oh, it's shooting.
That's a lot of fire.
How do they have unlimited ammo?
It's blocked.
But what's that?
There's a jelly.
No, no, no!
Don't run past the jelly!
If you'll listen to me.
I don't think you will.
I don't think you will, Rio.
Rio!
Keep yourself safe, Rio.
What happened?
A wobble.
Not the wobble.
Major wobble.
I think there was a warehouse key in my room.
Let's go get it.
It's in the service staff quarters.
Area A.
Run.
She's so helpless.
No, don't turn back.
Jelly.
Oh, there she got it.
Oh my goodness.
Should we try going back to Gustav's room?
I don't know.
What the...
Middle I.
Run.
Right I.
Left I.
Nice.
Right I.
Oh we have to wait.
Tail!
Turn around.
Turn around little guy.
Tail!
Body!
That works too.
Right I.
Mouth?
Where did that thing come from?
Control staff quarters.
Run.
Okay.
Gustav skipped.
I'm scared to go back in here.
What if you say right door?
We can try that.
Room on the right.
Let's try that.
Where should I go?
Second floor.
Run.
I don't want to be here anymore.
But we also need to get the lockers open.
Room on the right.
Right door.
Second floor.
Chat send voice clips?
Wait, how would you guys send voice clips to me?
Through Twitter?
No way!
Try Gustav with the uh sound of u.
I did try that!
I did!
I tried!
I've tried Gustav!
Gustav!
I've tried it all!
I've tried!
Just Gus?
Gus?
Yes.
Gus' room.
No!
Stop!
Second...
Second floor.
Say room number.
There is no room number!
I feel like I'm getting gas lit.
Look at her.
She just gets tired of walking.
She is so pathetic.
Southern accent.
Gustav's room.
Stop.
Forward.
What?!
Stop.
I tried Gus!
It does not work!
Gus?
Gus' room.
Okay guys, we can't fumble this.
We can't fumble this.
Oh my god.
I'm just not even going to tell her to do anything.
I'm not going to tell...
Read this.
What do I say?
Two chloro, three methyl butane.
I need to do a victory lap.
What?
Where is she going?
Go back!
Go back.
What did she do?
Go in there.
Go inside.
Where is she going?
What happened?
Oh, I got a key card.
She said there was nothing else.
She picked up an ID card.
That's it?
That was it?
Do you think...
Oh, I wonder.
Locker ID.
Oh, they do have the locker stuff.
Lockers.
The ID cards have their locker number on it.
Actually, you know what?
Hopefully this is worth it.
This might be worth it.
I'm babbling, baby.
1-5.
1-5-5.
Jonathan's locker.
No.
Lockers.
Okay.
You guys, I will save after I finish this part.
Don't worry.
You don't need to scream at me.
Okay.
Gustav.
1-5.
1-5-5.
Okay.
It's full of candy.
I don't think this guy is right.
I don't think this guy is okay.
He's spending...
799-4265 7...
Shit.
Oh shit.
I can't select it anymore.
Lockers.
Okay.
There we go.
7-9-9...
4-5-6-2...
No.
4-2-4-2.
6-5.
Thank you.
What is that?
Save point.
Congratulations on surviving the Oh No Room.
Thank you.
Now I understand.
We defeated the evil.
I can't believe we spent like over an hour in this room alone.
I can't believe we spent over an hour in just this room.
That's how I feel right now.
Alright.
We're going to leave room.
Leave room.
Leave.
Yes.
Run.
Oh my god.
Leave room.
You should go to the service staff quarters.
Go to service staff quarters.
Yes.
I'm exhausted.
I'm...
I'm so tired.
I'm exhausted.
Hold on.
I have to have some snack.
Oh my gosh.
She can do something for herself for once.
What are you eating?
Oh my gosh.
So...
What is this?
It's awful.
This is bad.
The absolute malicious intent.
The person who named that character in a way that rhymes with go and stop.
Evil genius.
Wait.
I'll tell you what I'm eating.
Middle eye.
Right eye.
Root.
Run.
Enemy 2.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Run.
Oh my god.
I don't know how to...
Dodge.
Rhymes.
Hey guys.
I don't think you know what the strafe does.
Strafe.
Strafe is just her shooting.
That's all it does.
Strafe.
Reload.
I don't think they know what strafe means.
Because I know what strafe means.
But strafe left.
See?
It doesn't work.
It's really stupid.
Strafe.
It does give good damage though.
Stop.
Oh.
She died.
Oops.
Sorry.
I didn't realize she was almost dead.
Anyway.
The thing I'm snacking on is...
It was a gift from Ayamimama.
And it's this Japanese...
Like snack.
Called Itoko no Rusk.
Itoko no Rusk.
If you are ever in Japan and you are able to get this.
It's so good.
Because this stuff is like the butter sugar.
And it's like...
They have different various types.
But this is like a candy...
Like a cracker version.
A biscuit version.
And it's...
It's...
I don't know how else to say.
Because it just literally says Itoko no Rusk.
Butter sugar.
But she also gave me another one that was like a soft.
And it had caramel and butter in it.
But this one is like...
This one is like a biscuit.
And I snack on it.
But...
Yeah.
It's so good.
I recommend this one.
The other one is still good.
But this one is...
This one is so good.
Itoko no Rusk.
It's my...
Osusume.
My recommendation.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It looks like broken waffle cones.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
That one, that one, that one.
It's so yummy.
It's so, so yummy.
It's a butter sugar flavor.
It's so good.
So...
Actually, this expired...
Last month.
I just noticed.
It expired January 12th.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I gotta get through it.
Okay.
It's just...
It's not gonna go bad.
Right?
It's like a biscuit.
It's fine.
It still tastes so good.
Anyway.
It's a best buy date.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
We're fine.
Probably.
But it's still soft and delicious.
The other one.
Oh my gosh.
The other stuff, it was a little too...
Buttery and caramelly for me.
Well, not caramelly, but like...
It was like, it felt like straight butter on the inside.
So what I've been doing...
Is I've been opening it.
I've been opening it up.
And putting it on waffles.
Okay.
Leave room.
Uh, hallway.
Yes.
Nice.
Actually...
Sincere?
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I was gonna say...
Oh, also, someone sent...
Rafi, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I was going to do...
She sells.
What?
Oh, okay.
Um...
Go to service staff.
Yeah.
Okey dokey.
Run.
Alright, this one is kind of tricky.
So we're gonna have to...
Do our best.
Yes.
Melt me on waffle and eat me, please.
No.
Sounds horrible.
Bad news bears.
Okay.
Yes.
Run.
Strafe.
Uh...
Yeah.
Enemy three.
Melt.
Okay, nice.
Move.
Strafe.
Uh... I didn't say leaf or anything.
Enemy two.
Mouth.
Sunny gifted.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Is it healing?
Vines.
Oh!
Strafe.
Forward.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Strafe.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, reload.
Nice, nice, nice.
Strafe.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Vines.
Strafe.
Yeah, reload.
Oh my gosh.
We actually did it.
Nice.
With minimal damage even.
That was pretty good actually.
That was actually pretty good.
Say it.
Tell me I'm pretty good.
Activate my...
I feel like a sleeper agent.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
What the hell is that?
We got a lizard in our room.
Rio, people are dying.
My pictures.
Where are all my pictures?
This is awful.
I just...
I give up.
What?
Rio.
There are so many mementos.
Don't give up.
Get a hold of yourself.
She's like okay.
Mental break over.
Gosh, I need to be as...
I wish I had a brain like Rio's.
She recovered so easily.
Wow.
Strafe, isn't that the twink from FF7?
What was I saying though?
Oh my gosh.
The other day my mom was like ranting to me.
About someone.
And...
Basically she wanted to complain to a company.
What did I come here to do?
But she kept...
She kept...
She doesn't know the pain of having to say Gustav.
I know.
But she...
She kept...
Referring to the...
To the manager as the big boss.
And I felt like a sleeper.
I was like mom.
This is a very serious conversation.
And I cannot take you seriously.
If you keep saying big boss.
I was like don't do this to me mom.
You don't know my brain.
And I felt...
I felt like I would be activated every time.
Activation phrase.
Truly.
What did we come here for?
What was that?
Warehouse key.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember.
My mom just kept saying big boss.
I'm gonna go talk to the big boss.
My...
I can never...
I can never exist in the same way.
Wait.
Is there nothing else in there?
Galley.
Heel capsule.
Nice suit.
There is a save point.
Save point.
Hot dog.
Thanks Richard.
Does she refer to the awful kids down the street as les enfants terribles?
I should tell her to.
Mom, you should learn French.
We have 2000 commands you guys.
You can call me...
Dominant.
Second floor.
Because I'm a dominant.
Do you get it?
And before big boss appears and says kept you waiting, huh?
Ok, Rio's room.
Oh really?
I just wanted to look in your room.
Ok, nevermind.
She literally goes up and says...
No, you don't even get to explore.
Rio doesn't want me to see her secrets.
Ok, Rio.
Alright then.
Go to hallway.
She is hiding something for real.
Why does she have a lizard in her room?
Why does she have a lizard man in her room?
What happened?
We should go to...
Go to warehouse.
Run.
Lizard.
Alrighty.
After the warehouse...
Since there was a lot going on in there.
I imagine then I'll call it.
The 21st of September.
Oh we got the night vision!
Uh oh, we got the night vision.
They were fighting in the dark?
Yes,
I can see you.
No, I'm a liar.
Uh huh.
Why doesn't she believe me?
Left.
Again?
You are testing me again?
None.
Yep, yep.
Both.
Yep, yep, yep.
The entire game is a test.
Oh my gosh.
In her mouth!
Run!
Enemy 2.
Tongue.
In her mouth.
There we go.
Nice.
In her mouth.
Eye.
Yes it is.
In her mouth.
Eye.
No, number 2.
In her mouth.
Nice.
OK.
Oh no, we just got...
Enemy 3.
Oh no, enemy... In her mouth.
In her mouth.
Yeah, reload.
Auto fire.
OK, good, good, good.
Eye.
In her mouth.
Uh, enemy 2.
Oh, reload.
Ah, in her mouth.
Enemy 1.
In her mouth.
Yes it is!
Auto fire.
Nice.
In her mouth.
OK.
Eye.
Nice.
In her mouth.
Actually aim.
Eye.
OK.
Yeah, no thanks to you.
Wow, there is a lot going on in here.
Area A2.
How does she know if she can't see?
Again.
Stomach.
Oh, that works too.
Enemy 2.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Nevermind.
Head.
Auto fire.
Oh, that works too.
Reload.
No!
I guess healing is fine too though.
Stomach.
Head.
Mouth.
Nice.
Stomach.
I'm washing.
I'm watching!
OK.
Area A2.
I don't think we...
Again?
Another?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Enemy 1.
Mouth.
Head.
Stomach.
Auto fire.
Oh my gosh.
Run away.
Stomach.
Not back.
Forward.
Forward?
Front?
Stomach.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Low kick.
Stomach.
Shoot.
OK.
Inner mouth.
Run.
Wait.
Enemy 2.
OK.
Alright.
Inner mouth.
Front limb.
Strafe.
OK.
Hand limb.
Body.
Strafe.
She didn't get a single freaking hit in.
Inner mouth.
Tongue.
Eye.
Inner mouth.
Reload.
ID.
Body.
Inner mouth.
Strafe.
That's what strafing does.
Inner mouth.
Oh.
Tongue.
Inner mouth?
Body?
I can't get a single freaking hit in.
Oh my god.
Inner mouth.
Shoot.
Auto fire.
Oh my god.
That's your fault.
Forward.
Inner mouth.
Strafe.
Oh my gosh.
Reload.
Inner mouth.
Oh finally.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot.
One HP and a dream baby.
Oh my gosh.
Finally.
Inner mouth.
Shoot.
She misses her chance every time.
Nice.
Shoot.
Oh yeah.
You need to do that.
Inner mouth.
Oh.
You know that works.
Holy...
Area A2.
These two steps forward.
How do you know you were saying hind...
Wait.
Did you know you were saying hand limb?
No I said hind limb, right?
Did I?
I don't know.
Oh.
Run.
Strafe.
Low kick.
Head.
Ouch.
Enemy one.
Turn around.
Oh my god.
Mouth.
Strafe.
I can't remember... Run.
Run.
I can't remember which one is for what with these guys.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Stomach.
Strafe.
Low kick.
I don't think it's that close.
Stomach.
Enemy three.
In front of you.
Run.
Stomach.
Enemy two.
Run.
No.
No please.
Run.
Oh my god.
Please run.
Run.
Please.
Please run.
I don't want to do this room all over again.
Stomach.
Reload.
Mouth.
Head.
Stomach.
Reload.
Oh wait.
No.
Enemy two.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Thank god.
Oh my gosh.
Stomach.
Shoot.
Enemy three.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Where are we anyway?
This area is so cruel.
They are going to really make us go through all of this with no save point aren't they?
They are really going to make us go through all of this with no save point.
Area B1.
Run.
There is a door.
Isn't that a door?
That's a door.
Area B2.
Recover.
Stomach.
Oh my gosh.
Enemy one.
Inner mouth.
Recover.
No, no please.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
Enemy two.
Low kick.
Inner mouth.
Body.
Enemy two.
Run.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Enemy two.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Head.
She actually dodged that.
Amazing.
Enemy one.
Run.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Enemy three.
Stomach.
Shoot.
Enemy two.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Oh my gosh.
Enemy one.
Run.
Head.
Stomach.
No, please.
Enemy one.
Inner mouth.
Enemy two.
Run.
Enemy one.
I can't see.
Inner mouth.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Okay, okay, okay.
Shoot.
Move right.
Oh, whoops.
Move left.
That works too.
Stage right.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Stomach.
Shoot.
I'm exhausted.
I'm so tired.
She sells.
No, please.
Please.
She just sells.
Area B2.
Oh my goodness, I'm so tired.
Oh, okay.
Doesn't B1 have a door though?
We literally see it right there.
This game feels like the microwave hallway.
But it's the entire game.
What?
Well, you can go to area...
No, no.
Area C1.
Wait, what?
C1.
Okay.
No.
Stop.
Did you say B1?
No!
Area B2.
Okay, I think I see where we have to go.
Like we get up here.
Then we go forward.
Oh.
Turn around.
You see it?
I see it.
But I don't know how.
Area C1.
Okay.
C1.
She listened.
Oh no, please.
Please don't get ambushed.
I know I'm about to get ambushed, but...
Recover.
Oh, thank goodness.
Enemy 2.
Blow kick.
Stomach.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Ouch.
Shoot.
Blow kick.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot.
Enemy 3.
Stop!
I'm in a fucking loop!
Stop.
Sorry.
No.
This is so unfair.
Move left.
Recover.
Run.
Enemy 2.
Stomach.
Stop.
Enemy...
Oh
my...
Try flee.
Does that work instead?
Flee.
Enemy 3.
In her mouth.
Shoot.
Strafe.
Enemy 2.
Flee.
Stomach.
Oh my gosh.
Flee.
Enemy 1.
In her mouth.
Run.
Flee.
Recover.
Reco...
Enemy 2.
Low kick.
Stomach.
Flee.
Oh.
Enemy 2.
In her mouth.
Shoot.
Low kick.
Please low kick.
Please.
Flee.
In her mouth.
Shoot.
Enemy 2.
Low kick.
Move left.
In her mouth.
Move right.
Heal.
Oh shit, shit.
Recover.
Move right.
Oh my god.
Stomach.
Flee.
Enemy 1.
In her mouth.
Eye.
Shoot.
Number 2.
In her mouth.
Wait.
No, I didn't mean to say that.
Sorry.
Shoot.
Eye.
In her mouth.
Shoot.
Stomach.
And number 3.
Enemy 3.
Turn around.
In her mouth.
Shoot.
Oh my god.
Forward.
Move left.
In her mouth.
I only have 2 health left.
I used all my heals on that one battle.
She won't do it.
She sells.
She will!
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Yes.
Rubber baby buggy bumpers.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Okay, your turn.
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Awesome!
Repeat after me.
I saw Esau kissing Kate.
Kate saw I saw Esau.
Esau saw that I saw Kate.
And Kate saw I saw Esau.
Okay, your turn.
I saw Esau kissing Kate.
Kate saw I saw Esau.
Esau saw that I saw Kate.
And Kate saw I saw Esau.
She sells.
Oh.
Yes.
Okay, your turn.
Oh, what did she say?
Sorry, I was checking my DMs.
The rugged...
She sells.
My pencil pleasure.
Thank you for membership.
Yes.
Sorry, I had an important DM.
Oh.
Rubber baby buggy bumpers.
Thank you.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
Okay.
Oh, this is a new one.
Okay, your turn.
Oh gosh.
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as it could chuck if a woodchuck could.
I did it!
Okay, we need to do it again.
Sorry.
She sells.
Okay, another one.
Yes.
Okay.
Around the rugged rocks the ragged rascal ran.
Awesome.
A big black bug bit a big blue bug and the big blue bug bled black blood.
This is a new one too.
Oh gosh.
A big black bug bit a big blue bug and the big blue bug bled black blood.
Why do you sound so desperate?
Because we need to heal.
This is how you heal in the game.
Well, this is how you heal without the... without the... what's it called?
The health packs.
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
Oh my gosh, I'm spitting everywhere.
Yippee!
I flubbed, but it's not as bad as the ESAW, I guess.
Okay, you know what?
That should be fine, maybe.
I know we're about to get ambushed again because there's so much time... or so much space to Area C2.
So...
Oh...
And we only have two more health.
Two more health.
Splash zone.
Okay, alright.
Go to Area C2.
Oh.
Oh what?
What light?
Oh.
It's all lit up.
What are you talking about?
All lights are currently turned off.
On.
Maybe leave the room and save.
Oh, true.
Oh my god!
Are those people?
Are they aliens?
Metal gear.
They look like sneaky suits.
What?
He sounds radical.
Oh my gosh.
What the hell?
Talking about the room?
Just shoot him now.
Just shoot him.
Oh.
They just had to make it exaggerated.
So evil.
Oh.
Oh hell yeah.
What is that thing?
Oh yeah!
I think we should leave.
I think we should go.
She's so hot.
Should I stay or should I go?
My heart is conflicted.
Don't touch me!
Our guns are useless against it.
Um...
Oh, me?
What should...
I'm gonna say run.
Run!
Seduce.
I would've done it for the bit, but I'm too afraid of dying.
I would've absolutely done it for the bit.
But you guys, I'm not doing that room again!
You can't make me!
Health pack.
I am.
I think we found our girlfriend.
Naomi.
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Go to area A.
Area A, okay.
I need to find a save point stat.
One second, you guys too.
Hold on, sorry.
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Where are we going?
Go to area C.
Area C, okay.
You see a save point?
Wait, wait, wait.
Save point!
I think you guys saved me.
Run!
Yes.
Oh my gosh, you guys saved me.
You guys saved me for real.
Save point.
Wait,
hold on.
No, wait.
I'm so stupid.
I don't want to go through that room again.
I was gonna try and seduce the lady.
It's okay.
We are in save point 2 now.
No.
Me.
Me after that room.
You know Rio, you know what would make me feel better?
Do a sexy pose.
Zoom in.
You all are so welcome.
You're welcome.
You guys say that I'm mean to you, but aren't I nice to you?
Zoom in.
I give you all the best fan service, do I not?
Turn around.
Stop.
Zoom in.
Look at you guys.
Okay.
Actually, now that I think about it, no one called that a fart window.
Only when it comes to me is it a fart window.
Zoom in.
That is literally what that is.
And yet...
Do a sexy pose.
Zoom in.
PNG.
Rio, wear a PNG dress.
Stop.
Fartome?
No!
That's not my name.
I'm not a fart.
I'm a phantom.
Well, not even a phantom, but you know.
I'm a ghost.
Don't get it wrong.
We do burn hats.
Can Mint do a sexy pose?
I don't even know how to be sexy.
Is that a sexy pose?
Oh, is that really a sexy pose?
I mean, I guess Senchou does it, so...
It has to be sexy.
She's very sexy.
After spending enough time with Rio, I cannot be freaky about her.
I can't force it.
Being freaky about Rio is like being freaky about a white piece of paper.
It's like...
There's just...
The only thing she's got is sass, you know?
Elaborate.
Well, she'll give you a paper cut with her sass, and then there's just nothing else there.
There's just...
That's... I... I just...
Basically, you...
What?
Are you saying I have no personality?
And that I can only take orders, and I can't do anything for myself?
What is this?
Aren't there any instructions?
Mint is a white girl, not white paper.
I'm sorry, I'm a ghost.
That I have white hair and, you know...
Give her instructions?
What's camera check again?
I don't remember.
Oh yeah, there is microphone check.
Aren't there any instructions?
Instructions?
Anyway...
Vtuber wink now.
You can't tell me what to do!
I won't wink for you, for your satisfaction!
Spin gun?
You can only do that in battle, unfortunately.
Also, we have a big gun now.
How do we spin it?
Remember, as janky as Lifeline is...
It will never be the level of frustration that is Hey You Pikachu.
And it's even jankier, Mike.
I think this is probably more frustrating because it's more... it's life or death.
You know?
From what I watch of the stream, I feel like being freaky about Rio might be ethically dubious considering how she follows directions.
I mean, she also wants to go to the bed all the time, so...
I don't know.
Great job getting past some tough bosses such as the spider, the bathroom, and Gustave's room.
Have a good night!
I think I'm tired for now, guys, but thank you for more, Lifeline.
This was... this was questionably fun.
No, I am... I am getting very frustrated, but I am having fun.
How far am I in the game now?
I think, what, was that part three, probably?
Oh, there's no white paper.
Where are we?
I'm gonna check the guide.
Thanks, TriPrincess!
Oh, thank you!
It's fun to watch.
I'm sorry, I feel like I'm shouting in you guys' ears the entire time.
I'm like, shout, shout, shout, because I'm getting so heated.
I need her to listen to me.
I feel like I'm yelling in you guys' ears, I'm sorry.
It's so loud, so I'm like yelling over myself, too.
Anyway, hold on.
This guide kind of sucks.
This guide is not... wait.
Can you hear me?
Oh, wait!
I think we might be, actually...
Not so far left of it, I think.
Shabir, thanks for the dono!
MintoGaming, you persevered.
Boss, this is why you're the best.
From what it seems like, we got through the control staff, service staff, warehouse...
I think maybe...
Maybe...
Next stream, we could endurance it a little bit.
So, yeah.
The clothing change was about halfway.
Ah, okay, so we're over halfway.
Nice, nice, nice.
Another stream or two.
We'll see how I'm feeling next time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good stuff.
Good stuff, good stuff.
The final boss was Gustav.
Honestly, that took so much time.
That took an egregious amount of time for me.
Okay, I gotta go.
Okay, I gotta go, guys!
Otamito, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I will see you guys...
Tomorrow, I'm playing...
Actually, I have to see what this voicemail is.
Actually, my grandma went back to the hospital today.
And my mom called me.
Yeah.
Okay.
Otamito!
Thank you, guys!
We'll see if I'm playing tomorrow.
We'll see.
Okay.
Otamito, otamito.
Bye bye, everyone!
Thank you!
See you later!
Bye bye!